hello everyone here on the freecodecamp
channel today today i'm going to be
showing you how to build every tool that
a startup needs thanks to this amazing
low code approach we are going to be
using this low code approach to build a
marketing dashboard in which you can
view all your users on a certain page
and then on another page you can choose
which users which are associated with
different marketing lists should be
emailed or sent messages to on discord
we will also have the option of adding
new customers directly from this
dashboard editing them as well as
deleting them as well as adding new
marketing lists too okay so a lot to
cover in this tutorial we will be using
mongodb we will also be using the smtp
api as well as the discord web hook so a
lot to cover
for those of you who don't know me my
name is anukuba and i'm a software
developer as well as content creator
online you can find me on my channel or
just here on freecodecamp
now before we get going low code
solutions are not to be confused with no
code solutions in which no coding is
required we will be using this platform
right here smith in order to drag and
drop ui components have been pre-made
for us and all we're going to be doing
is hooking up the back end okay so as
you can see here a basic understanding
of http requests such as get post put
delete are required as well as some
basic javascript too
this course has been possible thanks to
a grant from appsmith the low code
solution platform
okay so first things first i'm just
going to head over to the appsmith
platform which we will be using to build
our low code app
so if you sign in this is what your
dashboard should look like as you can
see here i already have some previous
projects that i have built using this
platform we of course are just going to
create a new one so i'm just going to go
ahead and click the new button like so
and this will generate this new landing
page for me
now i'm just going to rename this so
that we can keep track of this on our
dashboard i'm going to call this
communications dashboard just like so
and click off it so that is saved
and once we have finished that we will
have the option to build with drag and
drop or generate from a data table so
i'm going to choose to build from drag
and drop so just go ahead and select
that option so that we can start
completely from scratch on a blank
canvas just like so
once we are here the first thing we do
is just get the ui for our dashboard
down so our dashboard is actually going
to have two pages let's start off with
creating our first page this is going to
be called customer data and it's going
to you guessed it hold our customer data
because we're going to want to have our
customer data on one page and then
options to send messages to our
customers based on the mailing list they
are on on the second page
so let's go ahead and call this customer
data so our page is now called customer
data and like i said let's get to
building the ui first
so to build the ui we have some widgets
to our disposal that are pre-built and
pre-made
styled up ready for our use
so if we click on the widgets here and
all i'm going to do is just simply
search for a container widget
and just drag and drop it you can use
the outline on this widget to
essentially resize it just like so and
if we click on it we can drag it around
so there we go there's our first widget
that we have used we can also customize
it thanks to the tab on the right
so here are the options for
personalization on this particular
widget and i'm simply going to choose to
change the color on this so i'm going to
change the background color to this
lovely green like so and we can do other
things such as change the border radius
as well
okay
so there we go that is now a customized
container we can actually also rename
these widgets
so i can choose to name this header if i
wish this is useful especially when it
comes to picking them out later when we
add functionality to some of these
widgets okay so that is what you can do
it is optional you don't have to
so once that is done i'm just going to
show you how to add text to this header
so we're simply going to search for text
in the widgets and drag and drop some
text
so once again if we now click on this
you will see all the options for
customization on this particular widget
so let's change the text in this to be
customer communications
portal so all i've done is just change
the text in here
okay and then once that is done we can
also of course resize it by grabbing the
border like so
the other things we can do are change
the color of the tags so i'm simply
going to select from the options here
and then we can also change the text
size so we have some standard words here
i'm going to choose to use the heading
one for this particular text
okay
so
great this is looking good and of course
i can just center it by using the
dragging functionality on the widget
like so
wonderful
so that is done and the last thing i'm
going to do is just put an image so once
again let's go to our widgets and i'm
just going to drag in a image widget
like so this is a little bit too big so
once again we can resize it using the
borders and let's just drag it to where
we need so that it clicks in place
now
once here we can simply just use an
image that is hosted on the internet so
this is a great library that i use or
i'm going to use for this project
there's loads of free icons for us to
use this particular one is just going to
be a folder like so
so there we go that is the url that i'm
going to need you can of course use any
url you wish
and
wonderful
so our header is looking good i'm just
going to resize this a tiny bit and move
on
the next i'm going to do is actually use
another container because in this
container i'm going to store our table
of all our customers
so once again let's just drag in a
container i'm just going to drag it over
here and give it the border radius again
of 30. so there we go that translates to
30 pixels
and once that is done i'm going to now
put some text in here so that our user
knows what this container is for and
this is of course going to be for our
customer data like i said so let's go
ahead and change that text to customer
data
and select this to be a
heading 2 so that it's a little bit
smaller than our main heading
so that was super easy the next thing i
want to do is just add in two inputs
that will let us order the table that
we're going to input in later by
whatever column we wish and then by
ascending or descending order and to do
this i'm going to use the
text
so i'm going to put in some text to say
order by like so so just drag in the
text and just change this to be ordered
by and the next thing i'm going to do is
use the select widget
so let's go back to our widgets and find
the select widget
and once again just drop it where we
need
just like so
so the select widget simply looks like
this if you click on it it will show you
all the options we have
all the options are represented by the
options on the right with a label and a
value
okay as well as a little search bar
so that's what it looks like we will
come back to this later when we get to
putting in the values that we
essentially want because we don't want
blue green red we want to order by the
table columns
okay
so this is looking good let's just
stretch this out so we can add a few
more things and i'm just going to move
this around like so so that we can put
in essentially another
select and another text widget
while we are here however i'm just going
to rename this as this is something that
i will probably want to pick out later
so i'm going to rename this to key
select
just like so
and wonderful
now in out smith an easy way to
essentially duplicate what we have just
done is to literally copy and paste the
widget so that's what i've done here and
now i can just use the same widget with
the same sizing the same inputs and
everything and just move it along to
here and of course we need to rename
this because as default this has been
renamed to whatever the previous widget
was with the word copy i want this to be
the border select
okay
so there we go we've got the two selects
let's now carry on before we get to
changing these inputs later
now finally for our table so to do this
i'm just going to actually go to our
widgets search for a table drag it in
here just like what we've been doing and
a table will be generated for us with
some dummy data
however we don't want this dummy data we
want data from an actual database and
this is going to be a mongodb database
so this is definitely something i'm
going to want to pick out later when we
get to writing queries and writing some
javascript so let's rename this let's
rename this to data table again we don't
have to do this you can of course pick
it out by the existing name this is just
for readability more than anything for
this tutorial so just keep that in mind
okay so i've just renamed this to
data table and this means that instead
of having all of this
generic data that has been added for us
by appsmith i want to
get some real data from my database so
to do this let's connect to mongodb
so all i'm gonna do is head over to our
data sources and then once here well we
actually need to make our database first
so let's head over to mongodb and just
sign up for free let's go to mongodb
atlas and i'm just simply going to sign
up now i've already done the sign up
process for this if you haven't please
pause here and do the sign up process as
if you you know have never used this
before if that is the case or just sign
in if you have already used mongodb
i'm going to choose to log in with my
account that i use for mongodb tutorials
and
amazing
so this is what my dashboard looks like
as you can see there are a few projects
that i've previously done
but we are gonna have to create a new
project
so what should we call this project i'm
just gonna call it communications as
that is the app that we are working on
it's a communications dashboard
and once we have named this whatever we
wish
i'm just going to go ahead and click
here
and this will take me to
the next step in which we add members
and set permissions well this is easy
i'm just gonna add myself really so
let's go ahead and create our project
okay
and
wonderful now let's build a database we
are of course going to use the free
option for this of course you don't have
to this is just for the secret to
tutorial so i'm going to click on the
shared option right here and now let's
go ahead and select some of these
options
so the shared option well this means
that we can only use some of these i'm
going to go ahead and stick with the one
they are suggested for me and create a
cluster
once this cluster has started to make
let's just fill out these security quick
start questions let's give our database
a username and password i'm just going
to go ahead and make my username
annakubo and the password i'm going to
use is one two three
and i'm just going to create my user of
course please choose something more
secure again this is just for tutorial
purposes so i'm fine with that
and wonderful let's also add my current
ip address this just means that i will
only be able to access this from my
current ip address okay
so that will be the same for you if you
try to access your database from another
ip address it won't work thanks to this
and let's finish this
out
and wonderful so now our cluster is
being created
once that has done you should see
something that looks like
this
okay and now we are ready to
start our first collection so let's just
click on cluster 0 right here and on the
collections let's create our first
collection let's add my own data and
call our database something i'm just
going to call it data for now and our
collection name where we're going to
have a few things in here we're going to
have a
customers
collection in which we're going to store
all our customer data okay so let's just
go ahead and call this
customers and click create
so now you will see that we have data
and then a collection called customers
and if we want to add another collection
just go ahead and click the plus sign
right here and checking that you're
under the database name data just go
ahead and add a collection name of
mailing list in which we're gonna store
all our mailing lists for our app
and just click confirm again
and once again a third collection we're
gonna have three collections for this
project it's to be a marketing list so
once that is done just go ahead and
click create
and
wonderful so there we have our three
collections in the database called data
now i'm gonna just add some customers in
here manually to get started okay we are
going to be able to add customers from
the dashboard itself but just to get
going we're going to create some and add
them in manually just so we have
something to work with
so to do this i'm going to insert this
first customer into the customer
collection as you can see an id has
already been generated for me thanks to
mongodb and i'm just going to choose
this json
option just because i prefer working
this way you can choose the other option
but for me this is slightly easier as it
allows to copy and paste and just really
kind of you know create these customers
quickly as we are going to create 10.
so don't forget the comma
and what is our customer object going to
look like well
we are going to have a user do not
disturb and this just means that the
user has chosen to not be to start okay
so that is an option that we're going to
have for our app the next thing we're
going to have is a customer email id
which is simply just going to be an
email address for that customer so let's
go ahead and do that now
and just fill it out again this is all
just random data of course these emails
you know i don't know if they exist
maybe they do but they are just dummy
data
the next thing i'm going to do is just
have a customer id that is separate to
the document id above this is a customer
id that i have chosen for the customer
let's start off with z1001
and then we're also going to have a
customer name and this is what the name
of the customer is that the customer has
chosen to be represented by
okay so there we go this is our
essential customer object now i'm going
to copy this so that we can use it to
create way more customers and i'm just
going to insert this into the collection
just like so there we go there we have
our fast customer let's create some more
so i'm simply just going to insert a new
document
click on the json option put in the
comma paste away and then i'm just going
to
format this a little bit change the
customer id
change the email id so i'm just going to
make something up once again just like
so change the customer name so once
again i am just making this up and click
insert
so there is a few of these to go
i'm just going to do one more and then
i'm just going to fast forward them for
you because you know you should probably
get the gist by now and there should be
10
so once again i'm just going to insert
into the collection choose the json
option
format this a little bit better and then
i'm just going to change the customer id
and of course the customer name to once
again something that i am making up and
click insert
okay so there we go like i said i'm not
going to put you through all of this so
i'm just going to fast forward and cut
this bit out until we have 10 customers
in our database
and wonderful so there we have 10
customers in our database right now
there are 10 in here
so there we go and now we can use this
in order to populate the table in our
app
so
great so first off we're going to have
to get the
url that we're going to need to connect
to our database so to do this i'm
actually going to go to the overview of
this cluster 0 and just click on the
connect
once here we are going to choose the
connect our application option
and let's go ahead and just get this
whole connection string right here so
just go ahead and copy all of this
take it and we're gonna go back into our
appsmith portal
and then under the data sources i'm
going to create a new data source and we
already have mongodb configured in here
to make our lives a lot easier so select
the mongodb database option
and then
right under here let's go ahead and
choose the connection string option and
then paste our connection string in here
making sure to remove my first database
and change it to
data
and then also change the password to 123
or whatever you chose to save as your
password okay
great now we also have to whitelist
these ip addresses so just where we
added our own ip address we can add
these two right here so let's go back to
mongodb now and just close this
and under network access
i'm going to add an ip address
so all i'm going to do is just paste in
one of the ip addresses from the app
smith page
and click confirm
and let's now go back to appsmith grab
the other one
and then once again go back into
monkeytv and add that ip address
and i'm simply going to paste it once
again and click confirm
so super easy that is currently pending
but once that is done we can go back to
appsmith and we can of course test the
connection
so let's go back in there now
and then
of the three buttons just select the
third button and
great
this data source is valid let's go ahead
and rename that once again just for
readability i'm going to choose to call
this communications data just so that we
know
what we need to find and it's just a lot
more easier for us to work with
so great so once that is saved
let's carry on
so now let's go back to our customer
data page and click on the
table
just like so and get rid of all this
dummy data and instead we are going to
write a query so let's go ahead and
click on the
queries js right here on the left
and create new or we're going to select
the communications data option
that we just made as a data source
so let's scroll down and find that one
right here
and then you should see this page pop up
so now we are writing our first query
okay so to recap what we first did is
created a data source and now we're
writing a query okay that will use that
data source
so our query let's go ahead and call
this something i'm going to choose to
call this
find
query because we're going to find all
the customers okay and just return them
so making sure that is connected to the
communications data i am now going to
choose the command find documents and
look in the collection customers
okay because that is what collection we
want from our database quote data and
you're just going to click run
and there we go you will see all the
customers that we created in the
previous step when we manually added
them on mongodb
easy right
okay great so this is looking good now
let's go back to our custom
accumulations portal and once again just
get rid of all the dummy data once we've
selected the table data widget and then
i'm going to use these two kylie braces
so these two curly braces are an app
smith thing it will just allow us to use
the queries and not confuse the app by
thinking it's text
you can use javascript inside any widget
to control things like its data source
behavior and formatting just wrap the
javascript in double brackets to
separate it from regular text similar to
mustache or handlebar syntax
this allows you to link widgets to apis
queries and javascript functions and is
known as binding the widget
so i'm just going to use find query dot
data
and
ta-da that has brought back all our
customers it has arranged it in columns
for us it's got all the data it's very
intuitive this is wonderful
okay
so this is looking good the next thing
we're going to do is just customize this
table a little bit more
so what i can do is make some of these
columns not visible as we don't need
some of this information visible to the
user using the app one of these things
is not making the id visible and the
other thing is just making a new column
called a delete column so to make a new
column i'm just going to go ahead and
add a new column and let's just change
this to say delete just like so and
instead of having text in this delete
column i actually would have an icon
okay so i'm going to show you how to do
that now
so to do this just go ahead and click on
the little cog and it will show you all
the options that we can have for this
column
so the column
type well we don't want plain text we
want an
icon
so let's just go ahead and select icon
from this drop down right here
and
great an icon button has been generated
for us
now we can customize this further for
example i want the icon to be a trash
can so let's go ahead and select trash
and
great now because this is more severe i
also want to change the color so let's
go ahead and change the color of this
trash can so i'm simply going to change
the button color to be this
red like so
and
great
and then just just round it off a little
bit too
so of course this has no function
analogy at the moment but i really want
to show you what it's like to not have
text in the columns you can have icons
you can have buttons you can have
whatever you wish
we will be hooking this up later so just
bear with me for now
so now that we have that i'm just going
to actually
add a modal that will pop up when the
delete button is clicked
so again we are just doing the ui for
now we will do the delete query a little
bit later so to do this i'm just going
to go back into the widgets
and just search for the modal widget and
just simply drag it over and place it
under here like so
so once we have the model here i'm just
going to change the text i'm going to
change the text to say delete row as
that is what the model is going to be
for we're going to confirm that we
definitely want to delete this
line
so once that has been changed we can
also do some other personalization
let's also rename this to delete modal
okay
so for example i'm going to add some
more text in here so let's go back to
the widget and search for the text
widget and just paste it in here like so
and then we're going to have a warning
message that says are you sure that you
want to delete this item because i want
to make sure that people are definitely
sure that they want to delete it and
we're just not deleting the line if
someone clicks on it by mistake
so great the next thing i want to do is
just change the text of these buttons so
let's go ahead and change this from
close to cancel because you can change
the text of these buttons quite simply
like this
and by default this already has an event
the event is to close the module that we
have renamed delete modal
okay so that is in there by default
and
next i'm just going to
change this to be a primary button and
i'm just going to change the color of
the second button to be this red
just like so and on this click when we
confirm we want to delete the row we're
actually going to execute a query okay
we're going to execute so this is where
we get to writing the delete query we
want to execute the delete query
so let's on the on click event
select well this time i'm actually not
going to choose to just execute a query
i'm going to change some queries
together which is why i'm going to just
choose the javascript option so i can
write my own javascript in here
so to do this just click on the js
button until it's turned blank and we
are going to run the query delete query
which as i said we are yet to write
so we would do delete query run
and then this
function so we're essentially chaining
functions in here so once with the
delete query runs we're going to run the
find query
the find query is the one that will
bring back all the customers again once
the customer has been deleted so
essentially refreshing our data to truly
represent what is in there okay
and then we are also going to close the
modal so we're going to write close
modal and the modal we want to close is
the delete model that we have just
created
so that is how you would do that
chaining all of these things together so
that they happen in the right
order
okay
great so of course delete query does
have some little red squigglies under it
because we don't have that query yet so
appsmith is telling us that this is the
case and this will be an error so why
don't we get to
writing
that query
okay now we're going to actually hook up
the button to open the module so that we
can open it so i'm just gonna do that
now quickly
just on click
event and change that
while i'm here i'm also gonna delete
this icon we've done it this is looking
so so good
so
all i'm going to do is just under here
go to add query create new making sure
to select the communications
data
and this query is going to be a delete
query so let's just name this delete
query for readability
and the collection we want to work with
is the customer collection and the
command we want to do is delete document
and how we're going to delete the
document where we're going to search for
it by the
id
okay the object id
so
let's go ahead and choose the object id
that we are deleting
so this is the syntax for working with
mongodb we're going to have the id
and then we are going to get the object
id of the table
data of the data table so essentially
the table we called data table on our
dashboard and then we're going to get
the triggered row
id
okay
so that is how we know that we're going
to delete the correct row we're going to
select it from the table of the
triggered row and then pass it through
into here so that it gets sent off to
mongodb and deletes the correct one by
the object id
okay so hopefully that makes sense just
to make sure this is working let's click
run that
and now let's check if it works so let's
go ahead and choose one of these i'm
going to choose the first one
and click on the delete icon
click confirm
and then
ta-da
that has now been deleted from our
database so that has worked
okay the delete functionality of this
app is now working
so
let's move on
so this is all great and of course this
table does actually come with some cool
stuff that will allow us to search for
things with the search bar it will also
allow us to filter so for example we can
filter by any one of these columns okay
like this and we can do you know users
do not disturb is exactly zero for
example which of course will bring back
all of them because i believe they are
all zero at the moment but it just goes
to show all the options that you have
available to you just by using this
table widget like
this
okay
wonderful
so now that we have that done i actually
also want to
do my own custom ordering so let's go
ahead and use these inputs the select
drop downs that i have made the first
thing we're going to do is just delete
all of these actually we can just use
this as a template and let's change out
the labels and the values
so i want to be able to sort by
three things i believe i want to be able
to sort by the users do not disturb
so let's just make the value the same
like so
and then let's also set
and then let's also order by the
customer name in fact there is one more
thing we can choose to order by and that
is the customer id so let's just go
ahead and put the label as customer id
and the value as customer id 2.
great and let's also have a default
value and i'm going to choose for this
to be customer id
okay
so this is looking good uh as the
visible here i'm just going to actually
put in some js and that is just going to
say that only make this visible if the
find query data length is bigger than
zero
okay otherwise i don't want this to be
visible
wonderful
now do we need any actions well yes on
change so on change i actually want to
run the find
query
query again because i want to
essentially just bring back certain
values in a correct order in this table
so we're actually going to have to go
back to our find query
and add some stuff in there for this to
work but just for now on the unchanged
event or action we're gonna run the find
query uh query again
okay so at the moment this won't do much
uh but we will be fixing that a little
bit later for now let's do the ascending
or descending option two
so let's go ahead and select the second
drop down and once again let's change
the label to be asc for ascending and
i'm going to get this value of one and
the label to be d e s c for descending
and change the value of this to minus
one and delete the other options because
i only want two options here and just
like before visible is only going to be
visible if the find query data length is
bigger than zero so essentially saying
there's you know more data in there than
zero
now we run the find query and then i'm
also going to change the default value
to be
one so we're getting the value to be one
but the label for that is ascending
great
so this is looking
wonderful and on this we're also going
to have to change the
on change action and that is just going
to be to run the query find query again
okay
great
so like i said this won't do anything
now because we have still a bunch of
stuff to do and that is be able to run a
query
based on the
two selects that i have written which is
why we actually chose to rename these
selects as key selects and
order select so let's go back into our
find query and as the query up here i
just want to be able to sort
the data so under the sort once again
the syntax for mongodb used to have
these two curly braces and then i'm
going to use the appsmith two curly
braces so that the platform essentially
recognizes that this is not text and get
the key select selected option value
okay and then also the order select
selected option
value so that
things are sorted
by
the option and whether it's ascended or
descending thanks to the order select
drop down
okay
great
so this is looking good and of course if
we run this it will bring back the data
in the correct order
and now if we go back into our app
let's test it out
okay so let's go back in here i'm just
going to select the table and actually
on page change i'm also going to execute
the find query
uh query okay and also on the search
text change i'm also going to run it
just as a backup i just want to make
sure that this query is being run if we
change anything in here so that we're
always going to get the correct data
coming back
i'm just going to refresh this page to
make sure
amazing so this is now working this is
looking good let's go ahead and switch
some of these out again so
great this is all being sorted by
ascending and descending
order
okay wonderful so another part done we
have now finished making this table
sort by our
customized sort functions let's
carry on
now the next thing i want to do so we've
deleted stuff from the table we've got
all the data from the table the next
thing we're going to do is actually add
customers directly from the platform to
this table
so to do this i am going to choose
another widget it's going to be a button
so let's go to the widgets right here
and just search for the button widget
i'm just going to drag over so that we
can essentially connect it to a another
modal
so for now i'm just going to rename
whatever the label is for this button to
be new customer and we can actually add
icons as well to these buttons so if we
scroll down to all the options for a
button you will see the option to add an
icon i'm just going to put in a plus
sign like so and you can align it to the
left or right but i'm going to keep it
here i quite like that
now that we have that done let's go
ahead and find another modal in our
widgets so once again let's search for
the modal and then let's just drag it
down here wherever it doesn't really
matter and there we have our roso
so this model well i'm going to rename
this like we did before i'm going to
call this insert modal as that's what
it's for we're going to use it to insert
a new customer to our database
okay
so
there we go
and now let's go ahead and connect this
button so that if we click on the button
so let's get the on click event i'm
going to use it to open a modal
so just select the open modal option
and then the modal we want to open is
the
insert
modal
great
so now if i click on the button it opens
up the insert modal this is looking
wonderful it's exactly what i wanted
so first things off let's just change
the text of this just like we did before
to insert row
and now that we have that i'm actually
going to
put in some inputs here as to create a
customer we're going to have to have a
lot of inputs right
so let's go ahead back to the widgets
and search for the input widget
and let's change the name of this to
insert call input 1 again just for
readability so that we know what we need
to pick out when a time comes to it
so in here let's get this some default
text at the moment i'm just going to put
in this uh hard coded customer number
but we actually want to generate this
randomly i'm going to show you how to do
that in a bit and the label for this is
going to be customer id
so this is looking good and now let's
just space that out a little bit too
and
great
so there we have our first input that's
what it looks like and we've hard coded
a number in here this is not a
placeholder it is a hard coded number
and i'm just going to make this a little
bit longer just so that it looks
like
this
now while we are here i'm also going to
make this feel required we don't need
this visible toggle on
and
great
this is looking good
one last thing i'm going to do is just
make this bolt
now with the same technique we used
before i'm actually going to copy and
paste this input again so let's just
copy and paste it and then just drag it
underneath like so and i'm actually
going to do this a third time too so
that we have three inputs just stacked
over each other and just move some
things around so that it looks a little
bit neater and better so i'm just going
to move these buttons i'm going to move
them down here and space them out
equally at the bottom of our module
great
okay
so now that that has been copied i'm
just going to rename some of these so we
don't need this copy here let's go ahead
and change this to insert column input 2
and i'm simply going to change the label
as well to customer email id
okay and the default text for this well
we did default text we don't actually
want any default text we just want a
placeholder this time so i'm just going
to put in a placeholder email email.com
okay and same for the third one i'm just
going to rename this to insert column
input 3 and the placeholder text is just
going to be j and we're of course going
to change the label to to be customer
name
okay and let's just re-jiggle this a
little bit better so that it looks
nicer and
wonderful
now as promised the default text well i
want to randomly generate a customer id
so let's keep it the same format that we
have been giving so with a little c
and then a number which i'm going to
generate randomly okay so we're going to
use the javascript
object math floor to round down a random
number okay from essentially anywhere up
to
ten thousand
so math random multiplied by ten
thousand will do that for us so if you
use this and again using the kylie
braces so that appsmith knows not to
treat it like text
we will get a random number in this case
it is 1720.
amazing now of course this isn't
foolproof there is a chance that someone
gonna have the same customer id but this
is just for tutorial purposes so i'm
gonna say that it's fine for now
now let's move on i am going to now use
a switch so that we can switch if the
user wants to be disturbed or not so
let's go back into the widgets and i'm
just going to search for the switch
widget
and just pop it in right here and then
change the label to be do not disturb
okay
so there we go that we have the do not
disturb label and
okay so now what do we want to happen
well on the close nothing that needs to
change on this we're just going to close
the modal and on the confirm button
let's go ahead and change this to insert
button because we might want to pick
this out later and i just want to make
sure that we are picking out the correct
button which is why i've called this
insert button
and now on the confirm button well what
do i want to happen well i want a few
things to happen i actually want to run
a query that will insert this user which
way you have to write
but let's go ahead and do that because
we want a few things and again we want
to change them so on the on click just
choose the javascript
option so we can write our own
javascript and let's get up our two
curly braces and i'm just going to write
insert query run again we have not
written this yet and inside i am going
to put a callback function that will run
the find query after we've inserted our
new user so after the insert query runs
we then want to run the find query so
we'll find all our customers again and
then we want to close the modal so once
again we're going to use close modal
and we are going to close the
insert modal
okay
so while i'm here i'm just going to
rename this button to reset button
and
let's carry on
so now let's get to writing our insert
query once again i'm just going to click
on the add query js create new new
communications data and call this insert
query
now what does our insert query look like
well we are going to
want to
of course
the command we're going to use for this
is not going to be find documents it's
going to be insert documents the
collection we're going to work with is
our customers collection and the syntax
we're going to use well this is mongodb
syntax we're going to insert the object
essentially into our customer collection
so for this we're going to get our curly
braces out to create an object and we're
going to get the customer id
now as the value we are gonna go into
okay we're gonna go into the input which
we called insert column input one and
we're gonna get the text
whatever's in there
okay so that's what we have done
and then the next thing we're going to
do is get the costs let's call this
customer
email id just like we did in mongodb
and once again as the value we're going
to get our two curly braces up so it
knows not to treat this as text i'm
gonna go into the insert column input
two and get the
text
okay just make sure that this is all
spelt correctly just like we did in the
collection okay so maybe it's safer just
to copy this and just paste it like so
to prevent any spelling mistakes
and then again let's get our kylie
braces up and get the insert column
input three text
okay so there we go
and
now we also need the users do not
disturb so let's go ahead and get that
one
and wonderful and of course we need the
curly braces and this time we're gonna
get the switch one and then we're gonna
get the is switch on and if it is we're
gonna return a one and if it's not we're
gonna return a zero
cool so that is how we are going to
control if a label is switched on or
not
okay
so if it is it will assign the values uh
one and if it's not it's going to assign
the value of zero
great
so i believe that is it let's just have
a quick check to see if this is working
so let's go back of course don't forget
to run this first
and let's go back to here let's click on
the new
customer okay and then a random id has
been generated for us let's put in a
customer email i'm just going to put
tests at test.com the customer name of
course
let's
again just put in something in here i'm
going to put in test
user and do not disturb i'm just going
to keep that as it is and click submit
and now if we search in here
amazing our test user has been added
this is looking so good everything is
working our insert query is working and
we have successfully added a new user to
our database from the dashboard itself
great so now let's carry on
the last thing i want to do so once
again we've got all the data we've
learned how to delete a customer from
our database we've learned to add a new
customer from our database and i want to
edit a new customer in our database so
i'm just going to do this to the right
of what we have built so far so i'm
going to get a container so once again
let's search for container
let's make this a little bit smaller so
that it fits and then i'm just going to
drag that in here
once again i'm just going to customize
this a little bit thanks to the options
that we have and i'm just going to give
this a border radius of 30. okay
so that's what it will look like and now
i'm just going to drag in some text
so under the widgets i'm going to find
the text widget and i'm simply just
going to drag it in here like so and
call this update selected row
okay so i'm just changing the text just
so that it represents what we want to
say and then of course i can you know
customize this further i can give this a
heading 2
just to make it a little bit bigger and
great
now once we have that the next thing i'm
going to do is just put in some inputs
because we are going to want to change
some of the inputs that we have so to do
that we're going to populate the input
with the selected row that we have
chosen and then we also have the option
to change it so again under the widgets
let's just go ahead and find
well actually i'm just going to put in
some
yeah let's put in the input so let's
just drag in the input like so
this input i'm gonna name this
update column one
and the default text well it's gonna be
the
data table selected row
customer
id
okay so i'm just going to use whatever
row is selected on the left to
essentially populate this uh
this
input right here
valid i'm going to keep as true
and the label for this is going to be
the customer id
okay and i can choose to make the
customer id bold the label bold if we
just click this button right here
and
wonderful
so there we have it of course i need
more of these so let's use the same
technique before and copy and paste this
widget to create some more widgets
so once again let's rename this to
update column two
this time make the default text the
selected row customer email id and of
course this means we need to change the
label to customer email id as well
okay and once again i'm just gonna copy
the third one change this to update
column three change the default text to
be the customer name and then just
change the label to be the customer name
as well
great so now let's check if this works
let's selects a different row
and
amazing so that is changing everything
is looking good
now of course we also need the switch so
let's search in the widgets and i'm just
going to search for the switch widget
i'm going to paste it in here and then
of course change the label of this i'm
going to change it to users do not
disturb and then we can change the
alignment but i'm going to keep it as it
is
okay
so this is looking good and as the
default selected well once again we're
going to get up off two curly braces go
into the data table get the selected row
and get the users do not disturb and if
it equals one this is going to be true
okay
so as none of these really apart from i
think one equal one that should be false
the switch should not be clicked
and actually let's just go ahead and
change the alignment why not
and
great
so
amazing this is looking
good
i am liking this so far
now of course we need a button to
confirm that these are the changes we
want to make to the selected row so
let's go ahead and go back to the
widgets search for a button widget and
just drag it in here i'm just going to
rename this to update
button so that we know what we are
working with
the label of this uh i'm going to change
it from submit to update so that it
makes more sense and then on click we're
going to execute a
query this is going to be a new query
one that we haven't written yet called
update query so let's go ahead and
rename this to the update query and this
time we're going to update a document
we're going to do this in the customer
collection so let's just change that to
say customer and we're going to
just kind of like we did before
so the query we need for this well we're
going to go and look for the object id
so id and that's going to be the object
id of our
data table selected row id so just to
make sure that we are actually updating
the correct document
and then what are we going to update
well we're actually just going to have
to write the same object again with the
new values
so we're going to update we're going to
get up our curly braces we're going to
get the customer id and then of course
we are going to well in fact we can
actually copy this from the
insert query as it's just the same so
let's go back to our insert query and
i'm just going to copy all of this and
on the update query just paste it
however we are going to change the
widget that this is reading from right
so instead of insert column i'm going to
change this to update column
1
just like this
and of course update column 2 as that is
the column that we want to read from or
that is the input sorry that we want to
read from and update column 3 as well as
well as switch to
okay so just make sure to change those
up as well or change them up to whatever
you called your own widgets
great so let's click run and let's test
this out
so if i go ahead and just make sure
you're selected on one of the rows
if i go ahead and just change some of
this
so first off let's just make sure that
the button is actually going to run the
query so on click update query run and
then on success once again i'm going to
find
run the query find query okay
and also on error i'm just going to show
the alert so that we know that an errors
has happened and the alert is going to
say
error while updating resource okay so
this essentially is going to show up if
there is an error in our uh update query
running okay
great
so
cool shall we check this out
first off actually let's just make sure
that we can read this so to make sure
that the label appears on top all you
have to do is just stretch out this
widget
just like so i'm just reformatting it so
that we can see things a little bit
better and just in general making sure
that it looks a little bit nicer for us
okay
so we are now officially done with this
page everything's working we have
essentially we have essentially learned
how to get data from our database delete
data from our portal add a new customer
from our portal and update an existing
customer from our portal too
now the next thing we want to do is be
able to send messages to these customers
based on their options and what mailing
lists they are associated with so to do
this let's just go ahead and create a
new page
so to do this let's just go over here to
the left and all i'm going to do
is just press on the plus button next to
pages and a new page will be created for
me
once again we have the two options i'm
going to choose to build with drag and
drop and let's rename the page while we
are here i'm going to choose to call
this the send messages page so that we
know what is happening on this page
and now let's get to selecting our first
widget
in fact we can actually copy how the
customer data
page looks like i'm just going to select
the header and just paste it in here
like so which makes our life a lot
easier and let's rename this to be the
marketing portal okay just like so
just so that it's very clear that this
is separate to the other page and let's
go ahead and change this image too so
once again this is one i found on the
internet before so you can use it as
well or you can use your own it is
completely up to you
okay so it's a loud speaker here as i
feel that kind of symbolizes what this
page is going to be about
so next up i'm just going to start you
know creating what the layout of this
page should look like so i'm going to go
into my widget i'm going to search for
the container
okay
and then i am simply going to drag in a
container just like this and then i want
to put some text into this container
this text is going to be here and it's
just going to
show us essentially how many customers
we have to work with
so let's change the label of this to
total customers so go ahead and change
the text widget like so and we can also
change the text color now if i don't
like any of these colors i can choose my
own so i'm simply going to change the
hex value of this just like that so that
it's a lighter gray
once that is done i'm just going to drag
in another text
this time the text of this is going to
i'm just going to hard code it to be 0 0
for now we are going to change this
later this will be dynamic based on our
database and the amount of customers we
have in there but for now just leave it
as this okay and i'm just going to
change this to be a
heading
one actually let's make it a heading one
wonderful
so
once we are happy with what this looks
like i'm just gonna shift these things
around a little bit
okay just like so
i'm just going to put in an icon so i'm
going to search for the widgets once
again and i'm going to put in a icon
button to just paste that in here like
this and this is going to symbolize
visually what this section is all about
so i'm going to search for
people
so there we have our people icon and i
can also change this to be a secondary
button
just like this and we can also make it
more of a
rounded square if we want
i'm not going to give this any
functionality i just wanted to kind of
show what this section is all about
okay
great and let's also give a border
radius to the container itself so make
sure you're actually on the container
when you do this
wonderful
now again we want to show a lot of other
statistics too not just how many
customers we have so i'm going to copy
this whole container and everything in
it using the copy face functionality
and i'm just going to drag in wherever i
want these other containers
so there we go i do want four this is
going to store our major analytics if
you will
so let's change the name of this the
first one i want to say reachable
customers as this is going to hold the
statistics for our reachable customers
which is essentially all the ones with
do not disturb not on
and let's also change the icon for this
so i'm going to make this an icon that
symbolizes reachable customers
just like so so i'm going to choose this
one right here
now let's move on to the third analytic
provider
this is going to say do not disturb
customers
okay
so essentially we want to show how many
customers which have the do not disturb
on and let's change the icon of this to
symbolize that to with the blocked
person icon
and finally on the third one we're just
gonna have mailing list count and this
will just be how many mailing lists we
have on our dashboard and of course
let's change this to be some kind of
list
too
great
so this is looking good now let's get to
displaying the mailing list we have and
adding the option to add a new mailing
list if we wish as well as show exactly
who's on these mailing lists and then
add the option to message these people
as well
so let's do it
so once again let's go into our widgets
and i'm going to choose the container
just drag it in here like so and then
i'm also going to choose a second one
too
so once again let's give the container
the border radius this time of 15
and just do the same for the other one
as well okay so on the left we're going
to have our marketing list and on the
right we're going to have all the people
that are associated with that marketing
list
so to do this well let's actually just
put in some text to visually show what
these two sections are about so let's
just drag in some text and i'm just
going to rename this to marketing lists
okay just like so and make sure this is
a heading too
just so that it's a little bit bigger
and we can read it
great
and once again for the other side just
drag in some text and this time let's
give it the text of please select a
marketing
list to view the
users
okay
and once again let's make this a heading
to just make sure that it
kind of
fits in a nice
way
now we are going to use a cool widget
and this is going to be a list widget
which allows to map on different things
from our database directly onto a list
so if i search for lists and then i just
drag it in here like so
okay
there we go
at the moment it just has some default
values from the default values on the
right we want to replace this with our
data from our database okay but to do
this of course we're gonna have to put
in that data
so we will do this in a bit i'm just
going to finish off starting this
section first because we want to also
add a button to actually create a new
marketing list as well
so in the widgets let's search for
button and let's just drag in the button
and on the label i'm just going to
select new because we want to be able to
add a new marketing list and of course
we also want an icon to you know
symbolize that we're adding a new list
as well
great
so now i think i'm ready to start
using our data source which is the
communications data
to write a another query
so first off however let's go back to
[ __ ] tv because we need to add some
dummy data for us to start working with
so back in mongodb under the marketing
lists i am going to insert our first
markers in list
so go ahead and just make sure magazine
list is selected as a collection and
insert document and once again i prefer
to work with the json so just go ahead
and select that json option
so once again don't forget that comma
and what is going to make up our
marketing list well each marketing list
is going to have a discord web hook
because we are going to want to direct
anyone from this marketing list to a
channel on our discord so as an option
you can have so let's go ahead and put
discord web hook right here
and now i'm going to leave this blank
because i will be showing you how to do
this later when we start working with
the discord
web hooks
so just leave that blank for now i will
come back to it in a bit
the next thing we want to do is also add
a creation date so the creation date uh
well i'm just gonna put in a creation
date that i have pre-written for you in
the iso format okay so this is the
format that we are to use for the
creation date
okay
so there we go and the next thing i'm
going to do is put a mailing list and
this mailing list is essentially just
going to be the name of the mailing list
itself so on this occasion it's going to
be bugs because we have a mailing list
about people who want to know about bugs
okay the next thing i'm going to do is
just have the mailing list id which once
again is different from the document id
so let's go ahead and put in a random
mailing list id like so and finally
we're also going to have an icon
okay
so once again this is just an icon that
i have taken off the internet of a lock
you feel free to use this for tutorial
purposes or please feel free to use your
own
and finally we're gonna have the users
associated with this
marketing list
okay so
here we are here is the users associated
with this marketing list this is going
to be an array of users based on their
user id that we have written
so i'm just going to put in some users
in here again this is like kind of
random it doesn't really matter which
ones you want to use please feel free to
use whichever ones you
wish
okay so i believe we only have up to 10
so i think this is fine for now let's
just have these three
wonderful so there is our first
marketing list i'm just going to copy
all of this to make our lives easier
when it comes to making the next one and
insert this one into our marketing list
collection
great
so
this is now done let's go ahead and
create a new one once again don't forget
the comma and i'm just going to paste
this in here right so and reformat it a
little bit and i'm just going to change
the
a few things let's just change the
creation date let's change the mailing
list name this time it's going to be
products let's change the id as well
let's change the icon to so once again
this is one i found on the internet
earlier this is uh one of
a loudspeaker which we used before as
well so i'm just going to use this same
one for this and the users associated
with it well i'm just going to add a few
in here in fact perhaps maybe let's add
all of them let's just pretend that
everyone wants to know about the product
updates everyone wants to be on the
product mailing list
great
so there we have it i'm just going to do
a few more so let's go ahead and insert
another document don't forget the comma
format change the creation date name
change this mailing list name to be
something else so this time it's gonna
be feedback change the id as well and
i'm also going to change that icon this
time it's going to just be a hot
so let's just go ahead and change that
once again you don't have to use this
one please feel free to use whatever you
wish
and
sure let's just change some of these
users around and insert
okay so just one final one now to insert
i'm just gonna again use the comma
reformat change the creation date change
the mailing list to be all about
the welcome mailing list change the id
and i'm going to change this again so
once again just change the icon to
changing these few digits around and
just adding a cake
okay so again i'm not making this up
this is one that exists and it's hosted
on the internet and the users well we
should probably have all the users as
you know everyone should be on the
welcome list mailing list so i'm just
going to add all my users in here like
so
and just click insert
great
so
wonderful now that we have our mailing
list what we can do is of course go back
to writing our query
so i'm going to use the communications
data once again and the query we're
going to write is get marketing lists
okay
and we're going to find documents
and then of course the collection this
time is not going to be the customer
collection it's going to be the
marketing list collection that we just
added some documents too
so if we click run you will see exactly
that you'll see all the objects that we
made that will represent our mailing
list
wonderful
so
there we have it so now if i click on
the lists i'm going to just get rid of
this data
and we're going to use our query that we
have just written so the get marketing
list query and get the data from it
okay
so it really is that easy and now we're
going to use
that data to essentially map out things
onto our widgets in here so if i click
on the image
and get the current items
icon it will replace it with an icon
from the object that we wrote okay so
the current item is a list item thing
that will use the data that is coming
back to us and then it will just use
whatever we call this uh we call the
icon with a capital i so that's what we
need to get
and we can also just edit this text
right here so if i select this text and
at this time let's get the mailing list
itself so i'm just going to copy that
and change this to be current item
mailing list it will change it to the
title of the mailing
list
how good and how easy is that
so now i'm just going to delete this
second text i'm just going to reshuffle
some things just to make this a little
bit nicer and just so that we can
perhaps see more of these on the
marketing list first page
and there we go that is immediately
looking better i can see three at least
and this is looking wonderful it's doing
its job we are seeing all the marketing
lists to our disposal
wonderful
so now that we've done that let's
actually get to adding a mailing list
from the platform itself similar like we
did on the customer data page
so to do this we're of course going to
need a you guessed a modal so let's go
back to our widgets and i'm just going
to search for a
modal
so once the modal has been added again
you can just drop it anywhere we're of
course going to just change the text in
here i'm going to change this to create
new mailing list and i'm actually just
going to make this a whole lot bigger as
we're going to need a few things in here
so
what do we need in here
well
the first thing we're going to need is a
input we're going to need a few inputs
because we're going to have to
essentially replicate the objects that
we just made from the dashboard so let's
drag in our first input
and this input uh well let's change the
name of this to list id as that is what
it's going to
show and the default text for this again
we're going to randomly generate a list
id for this using an m to start with and
then the curly braces so that it knows
not to treat these javascript as text
we're going to use math floor to round
down the random number that is generated
thanks to the math javascript object and
random
method when it's multiplied by 10 000.
okay and valid well we're going to only
make this valid if the list id text
length is larger than zero
great
so that is how we do that and then the
label itself is going to just say list
id so that it's very clear to the user
that the list id goes here
and let's just make that bold as well
okay so once that is done i'm simply
going to copy this
okay copy that whole
widget
let's change this i don't want any
default text and i'm going to change the
label to be icon url so that people can
put that icon in here from the internet
to and let's just rename this to icon
okay so there we go and i'm just going
to put that up here and then just maybe
make it a little bit longer as well
because urls tend to be quite long
great so now let's go ahead and copy
this once more
and
drag it up here and this time i'm going
to name this list's name
and the default text i'm going to delete
as well and the label is just going to
say well list name
because this is where we're going to
store the name of our new mailing list
great
so
this is looking good of course we are
not yet done there's still a lot of
things to do
now once again we need another input
this time for the web hook so let's just
go ahead and i'm just going to remove
this valid
and change the label of this to say
discord webhook url just like so and of
course rename this to say webhook
okay
so there we go now i'm just going to
move these buttons down we can actually
select both of them at the same time so
that's what i'm going to do and i'm just
going to move them down here
okay so there we go i've moved them down
to the bottom
and now i'm just going to use a divider
just to space things out a little bit so
that is another widget that you can use
and of course just make sure that it
looks exactly how you want thanks to the
drag and drop functionality that
appsmith gives us
great
now i am also going to add an image so
that we can essentially preview the
image url that we want to use
so for this i'm just using the image
widget that i am resizing and that will
essentially show the image url that we
put in the icon url input
great
so we can do this by simply selecting
the image and on the image i'm going to
get the icon as that is what we call the
icon input text
okay so that should now work and the
last thing we want to do is just select
which customers from our customer
database we want to put into this new
mailing list we are creating so to do
this i'm going to select the table
widget i'm just going to grab the table
widget and just
paste it in like so by dragging it down
and of course we are going to get rid of
all the generic data that we have here
and we are going to essentially use a
query in order to get all of our
customers again so i'm going to call
this something different i'm going to
call it get all mailing list customers
okay
and this just means that we need to
write a new query based on the
communications data so i'm just going to
paste that in here like so i'm going to
find the documents and what i'm going to
do is look in the customers collection
let's just click run to essentially get
all our customers back
okay so again it's the same query wrote
in the first page we've just written
again and called it something else
so now let's just get the modal up again
i'm just going to do so this time by
just selecting the
modal so just here
okay so there's our model again and just
click on the table and i'm just gonna
make sure to get the data from this
query and i'm also going to filter out
each customer
by the
customer
user do not disturb equals zero
okay
so that is what i have done right here
and
i am also now wanting to add a way to
select multiple customers right
so before we do this i'm actually going
to make the user do not disturb not
visible as well as the id
and down here on the options i'm going
to enable multi-row selection so there
we have it now we can select multiple
rows essentially i'm also going to just
make sure that sortable is not true and
enable client-side search is also not
true as we don't need this
great so this is looking good i'm
selecting loads of different rows and on
the close button i'm just making sure
that the event to close does actually
close the modal modal one
so this is looking good
and on the second button let's actually
name this to form button one i'm
actually going to add a label and the
label is actually going to show us how
many customers we want to add to our
mailing list
so i'm going to use the word add and
then i'm going to use our kylie braces
to go into table
1
selected row length
okay so if we selected three from table
one it will show me the number the
number three and then i'm going to use
the words user to list and i'm just
going to show the list name that we have
chosen to call this mailing list
at the moment of course it's just
nothing because we haven't chose a list
name to put in the list name input
great
so this is looking wonderful and now on
click we of course want to execute a
query and this is going to be a new
query and this query is essentially
going to let us add a new list
to our mailing list
so add a new list we want to insert a
document the collection of this is going
to be the marketing list and the
document well we can actually go ahead
and copy all of this because that is
what we want our object to look like so
just go ahead and make sure to format
this correctly so i'm just getting rid
of all the spaces and of course the web
hook we're going to leave this as blank
for now and we need to add the double
quotes in all the right places too so
i'm just formatting this all a little
bit just like so for now i'm just going
to keep all of this hard-coded until we
finish formatting because i'm going to
have to replace some of these a little
bit
so now that we have all of that
formatted well the discord web hook we
want to get the value from the webhook
input or the input that we called
webhook and we want to get the text so
making sure that's in kylie braces so
that the platform knows that this is
not text okay
and again we're going to do so for the
creation date this time we're actually
just going to use today's date and we're
going to use moment for this moment is a
dependency an npm dependency that we can
use that has been already put into
appsmith for us
and to get the correct date we are just
going to format it correctly like so so
saying that you want the year the month
the day and the format that we used in
when we were adding the documents
manually in mongodb
okay so there we go and the mailing list
name well this is just going to be the
list name text again we are grabbing the
input which we have called list name and
getting the text that we put in that
input
and same for the mailing list id once
again we get the list id and its text
just like we did before
and finally we're going to get the icon
and this is simply going to be from the
input that we called icon and we're
going to grab its text
and
great
so now let's check if this works
let's go ahead and just select the modal
so up here because we haven't actually
connected the button to the model yet
and we also need to add the users and
the users is essentially going to be an
array of the users from the table that
we have selected so let's go ahead and
do that i'm going to call this users and
i'm going to go into table 1 i'm going
to get the selected row i'm going to map
for each element the customer id so
we're just going to return back the
customer id from each of the
objects
okay
so great so now let's test it out i'm
gonna go and find my modal because we
haven't hooked up the modal quite yet
we're gonna have to find it to get it up
and let's put in a list name at the
moment i'm just going to put test
let's find a test icon that we can use
and just whack it in here like so so the
preview is working that is good and
let's just select some of these so add
three items to the list test list and
just click the button
now on click what do we want to happen
well on click
we want to essentially
run the query add new list run and on
success we're just going to close the
modal and the modal is called modal one
perhaps we can change that later but for
now i'm happy with that being modal one
so let's run this
and check if that has worked
and great so there we have it we can now
see
our
new list our new marketing list
this is all looking
great
okay so now that we have managed to get
our marketing list and add a new
marketing list from the platform itself
let's get to actually displaying the
users associated with that marketing
list when we click on it
so to do this this is relatively simple
we're just going to grab the table
widget
so let's go into our widgets and find
the table widget and drop it in here
like so and we know what to do now we of
course need to get the correct data
shown up here so to do this i'm going to
write a new query so just go ahead and
click on the queries on the left and
we're going to use our communications
data
so let's just click on that and let's
call this get customer list
okay
so the get customer list well we're
going to find documents we're going to
look in the customers
collection and the query we're going to
write for this well we're going to have
to look if the customer id is
essentially in the marketing list we
have chosen so we can do so with this
mongodb syntax let's get up our curly
braces let's get the customer id and
using the dollar sign in we're going to
look and check if the list we selected
so the list
widget selected item
uses okay and if that exists then we're
going to return back the customer
associated with that id
first of all of course we do have to
select one so select one from the list
one and click run
now we aren't getting anything back
however let's just try sort by customer
id
so just put in this right here and just
try click run again
and that has not worked so we've
encountered our first
issue we need to debug so a quick way
that i would do this is just simply look
in mongodb
and check why the customer id
is not matching the marketing list id
and you will quickly see it's because we
used a capital c on the customer id and
we used a small c on the
marketing list so let's go ahead and
quickly change that i'm just going to
change these to small c's right here as
that would be the easier option so i'm
just changing all of these to small cs
just like so so there is 10 to update
i'm just going to quickly go ahead and
do that but that is how it would quickly
debug if some data issues are happening
i'd always go to the source i'd always
go to mongodb to check what that data is
looking at perhaps it's a string or and
you've said that it should be a number
it could be a variety of different
things on this occasion it's quite a
simple fix so i'm just making sure that
the id is exactly the same as what we
wrote in our marketing list
great
so now if you run this
tada we will get the data coming back to
us okay so these are all the users
associated with the marketing list i
selected on the dashboard itself so that
was the bugs and if i now connect this
so instead of using this data for the
table i'm going to get rid of this i'm
going to get up our curly braces i'm
going to use the get customers list data
and ta-da so now if i click on a
marketing list it will show me all the
users associated
with that
marketing
list
this is looking so good how easy was
that
now another cool thing we can do is
actually change the text in here to show
exactly what list we are looking at so
if i select this text i'm going to say
that i want it to say i'm just going to
cut all that because we're going to use
that later get up our two curly braces
i'm going to get the list one selected
row
i'm just going to get the mailing list
so that shows the name of the mailing
list we have selected
and if the length is bigger than zero i
wanted to show the list one
selected row mailing list
name essentially so just what we saw
otherwise i just wanted to show please
select a marketing list
to view users
and we can actually get rid of this word
users here because this users can be
used for either one of these so i'm just
going to get rid of here and put it
there
so now if you select on any marketing
list it should show
the
right title in the container on the
right
great
so this is looking wonderful
let's carry
on
okay
so now back on the table just here i'm
going to hide some of these columns so
i'm just going to hide the users do not
disturb and the id as we do not need
these things and i'm also going to
choose to have the primary key column as
the customer id
i'm also going to choose to write some
javascript to where this is visible or
not and this is going to be visible
based on if the list one selected item
id
is essentially larger than zero okay
so essentially if it exists
great
and one last thing i'm going to do is
actually add a
enable multiple rows selection so that
we can choose who we want to email from
this list as well you can choose to
email everyone but also we have the
option to not email them if we wish
wonderful
so now that we have that done we
actually need an option to email the
users so for this i'm going to use
another button
so let's go ahead and select a button
widget so that this brings up a modal
for us
so this button right here
and let's just go ahead and change the
text to say connect with
and then we're gonna have the
table
two
selected rows
length so make sure that rows multiple
length uses so it'll show us exactly how
many users we have selected at the
moment is one so it will say connect
with one users and if we select more
that will update to show us how many
users we have selected
okay
so
great and i'm just going to change this
visible and put in some javascript to
only make this visible if list one
selected
item id
length is larger than zero so
essentially if it exists
and we're also going to make this
disabled so again let's enable the
javascript if table two selected rows
length equals zero so if there is zero
selected this button will be disabled
okay
great so as you will see if i don't
select any that button is now disabled
wonderful and there we go we have now
enabled it again
so great and now of course we need some
events to add to this button so on click
what do we want to happen we're on click
we actually just want to
open a model this model we are yet to
create
so
let's go ahead and
create that modal
now
so
i'm going to go in here
and i'm just going to create a new
module and let's call this the message
modal as that is what this will be it
will be a message model that will
essentially send a email or a discord
message or both to the users we have
selected
first things first let's go ahead and
change the text of this i'm going to
change the text of this to say send
message just like we were doing
previously
and the message we want to send well
perhaps let's actually
make some options so i can do this with
a tabs widget so if you search for tab
widgets and just place it in here this
is what it should look like
i'm also just going to move these
buttons around so once again i'm going
to select both buttons and move them to
the bottom of my module
and this is to make the tabs stretch all
the way out and i'm just going to move
some things around in here just to make
things look a little bit better
once we are happy with the layout i'm
going to select the tabs and i'm just
going to change the tabs name the first
one is going to be the base text that's
going to apply text to both the email
and the discord and then i'm going to
have a separate tab for the email as
well in case we want to alter that text
and of course again for the discord in
case we want that text to be different
as well
so there we have our three tabs the next
thing i want to do is just actually put
in a rich text editor into all of these
so i'm just going to search for that and
i'm going to drop it in here
and first off actually let's just put in
some normal text
so this text is to show what exactly we
want to happen here and i'm going to say
i'm going to use actually some html to
make this bold
enter your base text and then just a
normal text i'm just going to put you
can edit this message
for
your email and discord from those
separate tabs
okay so that's just a little bit of an
explainer and the next thing we're going
to do is actually grab that rich text
editor and just put it at the bottom
like this
okay and of course we can have some
default text but i don't want to i'm
just going to leave it blank
and i'm actually going to grab all of
this and copy it and paste it in the
email section too and just change the
text of this a little bit so that it
better represents what is happening here
and that is just going to say write your
email
and this is really all i want in this
section
i'm also going to have an input perhaps
for the subject too so let's go ahead
and put in an input and let's put the
label as subject
and this is of course going to be for
the subject of the email
and also the one thing i want to do
before we move on
is actually
change this to say email text so that we
can pick out whatever's in the text
editor and that we know this is coming
from the email tab so let's change this
to email text and back on the
base text let's also change this to base
text okay
and finally on the disk or tab once
again i'm just going to paste everything
i did before and just change this text
around just so it better represents what
is happening here and of course we also
need to change this to say discord text
so that people know where this has come
from when it comes to picking it out
later in this tutorial
now one other cool thing we can do i'm
just going to move this up to show you
you can put this on all the tabs or you
can just have it here it's actually just
show a count of the characters
so i'm just going to do this simply by
grabbing the text
component or widget and dropping it in
here and instead of having some text i'm
going to use the kylie braces so that
this is not text and get the discord
text text length
okay and then i'm just going to put
characters so now we will know how many
characters are used in this discord text
widget
okay great
so now i did say that i would want
whoever is using this to choose if we
want a message on discord or email or
both so i think the perfect example for
a switch is this use case let's go ahead
and grab these switches
and i'm just going to drag one in below
the tabs okay i want this to be applied
to the modal and not the tabs and let's
change the label of this to say discord
switch and just put in another one that
will say email switch and we're going to
link this up later
and while we are here i'm just going to
make the buttons a bit bigger just so
they look a little bit nicer and just
make sure
that they are looking good and on the
confirm button we're going to execute a
query that will essentially send
messages
so
what we're going to do is actually write
a javascript object for this
so this is going to be a javascript
object as we're not simply just going to
run one query we're going to want to do
a lot of things in here which is why
we're writing a javascript object
so let's create a new javascript object
and i'm just going to call this object
utils just to make it more clear what
this is
and let's just go ahead and delete all
of this code right here as it is not
really needed
so now the function that we want to
write and essentially the
javascript
we want to call when clicking that
button is something called send messages
or as we are going to choose to call
send messages and what we want to happen
is
so if the discord switch or the widget
that we call discord switch is switched
on
we want to essentially
get the discord api to run so we are yet
to write to the discord api so for now
we will come back to that and we also
want to show a success message so let's
define our success message i'm going to
call this success message one as we will
have two
and the message we're going to have is
discord message sent to and i'm just
going to concatenate the
list
ones selected items mailing list so
whatever item we have selected from the
list i'm going to get the entire mailing
list and i'm going to concat server so
it's going to show us all the uh mailing
lists that we have sent messages to
discord messages too and we're just
going to put this in alert so show alert
and i'm going to put the success message
one in here just like so
okay
so this is great but also what happens
if the uh
email switch is on right so i'm just
gonna copy all of this
and change this out so if email switch
is switched on well we also want the
send email
query to run which again we are yet to
write
and let's just change the success
message i'm just going to name it two
just to differentiate from the other one
and i'm going to say email sent to
and to users on and i'm just going to
again concatenate it and just use the
word list at the end and show the alert
okay
and then i'm going to reset the widget
and the widget i want to reset it's the
message model and i want to close the
modal of message modal so resetting it
so we're emptying out all the fields and
we're closing that modal okay so that
will run after both of those if
statements have been checked
great
so
this is looking good
let's carry on
so now i think we've come to the point
where we should write our discord api
so let's go ahead and add a new query
i'm going to create a blank api and i'm
going to call this discord api and we're
going to have to grab a web hook of
course we don't have any web hooks yet
but we can actually just get the value
of the web hook so i can do so easily by
getting into the list and getting the
select rows discord web hook at the
moment they're all blank but that is
fine as soon as we populate them this
will work and as the key and value here
i'm just going to put the content type
and i'm going to fill this out with
application json so make sure to do this
like so
and of course let's also not forget to
get the body because the body is going
to be that of the discord uh
the one
discord text that we have associated
with the rich text editor on the discord
tab
so make sure all that is done and make
sure that this is a post request
and just click
run
okay
so now that is done let's carry on
the next thing we need to do is be able
to send emails
so again let's write our send email
query so to do this i'm actually going
to have to create a new resource and
just click on the smtp resource right
here and let's call this send email
so just go ahead and do that and now
let's do some configuration for your
gmail account
so if you have a gmail account i would
suggest if you don't have a gmail
account i would suggest you get one
because this is going to work with the
gmail smtp
so
the host address for this well the host
address for this is going to be
smtp.gmail.com
and the port there is a few so i'm just
going to put in two to be sure
so the port that we are going to use is
the port
5
5 8 7 and i'm going to put in the other
one too because you never know the
second port is going to be 465 making
sure to of course put the host address
as the same and we are going to use
authentication so authentication is just
simply the credentials you use to log
into your gmail account because we're
going to essentially be using your gmail
account to send out these emails
so i'm just going to put any free
codecamp.org and the password associated
with that account so that i can log in
to gmail
now you would think this would be it but
we are not yet done gmail uses some
extra security that we're gonna have to
configure
so i would suggest clicking run and you
will get an error message this is good
as it will show up in your email address
that some funky activity has gone on
so usc's sign in attempt was blocked
which is great but it also means we need
to unblock this attempt
so let's secure up blocks let's just go
ahead and click and get more information
on this and then i'm simply going to
scroll down in here
click on this button right here i'm just
going to verify that this is me
and i'm going to allow less secure apps
off be on okay so this will allow me to
give access to essentially all less
secure apps including this one so this
means that if i now click test
that should now work so don't forget to
do that if you have any issues that
could be y and let's carry on
so now that we have added our resource
sent email i'm actually gonna also have
to write a query so we've got the data
source let's write the query now i have
named this to be sent email so let's
just name the query send email again so
let's write a new query using the send
email data source
and i'm just going to call this send
email again
now the command we want to do is send an
email that is correct and from the email
address well that is just going to be
from my email address so i'm just going
to put in that in here just like so and
the two emails well we're going to have
to get the emails from the mailing list
that have been selected so once again
let's get our curly braces and i'm going
to go into the utils
and we're going to actually write our
own
javascript for this okay instead of
writing everything in here i'm just
going to put in the retails as that is
easier
so let's call this get emails and let's
have the subject of this be
communication sent via communications
dashboard and that is what this
dashboard is called and the body of our
email is just going to be whatever the
email text is
text okay so whatever we have in the
email text rich text editor text is
going to be body of our email and the
subject will never really change unless
we want it to
okay so if you want you can connect the
input that we have chosen for the
subject here but that is optional too
and oops this should say get
emails so let's just change that to get
emails and let's write this in our utors
file
so once again let's actually
describe this let's actually write this
out here so i'm just going to use get
emails and what do we want to happen
well what we want to happen is
we want to first define
the name array and that is going to be
the table to selected row
and for each row we're going to get the
customer
email id
so each customer email id or essentially
each email will be mapped
or essentially each email will be stored
to this name array
and we're just going to return the name
array to string
okay
so now we have essentially got all the
customer emails associated with the
selected row of the table
and this means that we can now use get
emails
so get emails
and just call it
okay
so let's check if that has worked so i'm
just gonna go ahead and try send a
message
so let's get up on modal
click on the email tab
i'm actually going to put the default
text of this as the base text text and
then we can change it if we want and i'm
also going to actually do this for the
discord rich text editor too so make
sure to click on that and under the
default text we're gonna go into the
base text and just grab the text like so
and of course we can edit this if we
wish
okay
so
wonderful
let's just check this works of course
perhaps we should put our own email in
here to email ourselves to
so let's just go back to the query and
i'm just going to put in my own email
address
okay and just click
run
so that says that that has been
sent successfully let's check it out
and great so i have indeed received that
email this is looking wonderful this has
worked and let's check if it works from
the dashboard itself so once again let's
just get up the model and click confirm
and let's make sure that this actually
runs the query
runs the thing that it needs to run so
let's click on utils and then let's
click on these send messages util
why is this red r we need a default tab
so let's change this to be
base text
okay great so we're sending emails
everything is working everything is
looking good
there's a last few things we need to do
and that is actually just hook up the
analytics on the analytics tabs and then
actually link up the discord webhook to
discord so first let's do the analytics
as that should be relatively easy so
let's go ahead and select this first
analytic and i'm going to write a
new
query so let's go ahead and create a new
query using the communications data and
call this
get all customers list
and this is just going to find documents
and it's just going to look in the
customers collection just as we've been
doing previously and i'm just going to
run it
and now this means that if i get the
kylie braces up and use that query and
just get data length it will show me
exactly how many customers we have in
that list which is 10 that sounds and
now we're just going to get the mailing
list count this is easy as we've already
written this query so just get the query
to get the marketing lists get the data
length and that's it
great
next one
so for this one we just want to show the
users that are reachable
i'm going to write a new query for this
in fact let's actually write this in the
utils file so let's get up our users
file again and i'm just going to not
forget the comma and write a function
that will essentially show us everyone
on the do not disturb list
so let's call this dnd list and i'm
going to save the dnd count and as
default it's going to be zero
i'm also going to say the reachable and
also make that 0.
now
what we are going to do is get all
customer lists so the query we just
wrote i'm going to get the data and for
each i guess user coming back to us
i'm going to get the user do not disturb
and if it equals 0 i want to add to the
dnd count however if it
does not equal zero i'm going to add it
to the reachable count
okay
so
great and then i'm just going to return
so let's define what i want to return
and i'm going to return an array the
first object is going to be for my
reachable so i'm just going to make an
object that has x as the string
reachable and y as the dnd count
and x
and the second object is going to be for
my do not disturb and y is going to be
the reachable
count
great and i'm just going to return this
so now i can use the util i have wrote
the dnd list of course we need to use
utils dot that is the correct syntax and
i'm just going to get
the filter the second item in my array
and get y to show the reachable
customers and then i'm also going to use
the do not disturb and the same thing so
i'm just going to copy and paste all
that but this time i'm going to go to
fast item from my array and get the
y
value for that
okay so seven reachable customers and
three on the do not disturb this is
looking correct
and great so we're nearly there the last
thing we need to do is i'm just going to
show you how to use the discord web hook
so for this you need to actually have a
discord account okay so get up your
discord account and if you haven't
already i want you to go ahead and start
a new server okay because we're assuming
that you own a server and you want to
message everyone on your server on a
certain channel about a certain thing
so for example i if i have a server and
i have a channel all about bugs i want
to everyone everyone on the bug's
channel
about the bugs
so to do this let's create a new server
i'm just going to put for me and my
friends and i'm going to create it
and now once i have done that uh let's
just i'm going to show you how to do
this on the general channel okay of
course once you know how to do this you
can connect the correct discord web hook
to the correct channel but this is a
tutorial so i'm just going to show you
how to do it and you can do it yourself
now on general i want you to go ahead
and just click on the cog and once
you're on here i want you to get
integration and just
essentially create webhook and copy the
webhood link
and once we have that i'm just going to
go on the first
marketing list
and i'm going to get the first
object and in here i'm just going to
paste it in okay so on the mailing list
of bugs that now has a discord web
link which will essentially just post to
my general channel on my discord but you
get the drift
so now let's check it out so if i go
back in here and make sure that bugs is
selected on the mailing lists and click
connect with two users
i'm just gonna go ahead and
click confirm
and great
so that has now been sent
amazing we've done it we've got the
whole app working this is looking
fantastic i hope you've enjoyed this
lesson we have a few more things to do
and that is just deploy this so just
bear with me
let's do it but i hope you've learned a
lot so far and i hope you know now how
to add your own discord web hook links
too so to do this all i'm going to do is
just press on this button right here to
connect to git and once done i need to
get a remote url to a repository well we
need to make a repository first so all
i'm going to do is click new right here
and create that repository i'm just
going to choose add a readme and create
now once that is done i'm just going to
grab this url like so and paste it in
here
i'm also going to have to give absolute
access to my repository
so let's copy this ssh key and go back
to github and now under settings i'm
just going to click deploy keys and add
a deploy key and add that key in there
and name it and click add key and that's
done let's just connect commit and push
and ta-da
let's preview what we committed and
there is our app and it is saved on our
github okay so there we have it there's
our wonderful app as you can see here
we've got two tabs we can send messages
we can also filter through bugs and all
our marketing channels and of course we
can see all our bug users and all our
mailing lists and everything like that
thanks so much again for watching i
really hope you've enjoyed this tutorial
and i hope you love your new app